depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
liée aux covit 19 les artistes ont
littéralement pris d'assaut les réseaux
sociaux pour conserver un lien avec les
fans et aider les confiner à se divertir
et passer le temps hier soir c'est le
chanteur dazhou qui a cette fois ci cédé
à la tendance dans un live instagram
pour la bonne cause le célèbre
interprète de rain a décidé lui aussi de
mettre à profit sa notoriété et son
carnet d'adressés pour récolter des dons
au profit de la fondation des hôpitaux
de paris et l'unicef en particulier pour
soutenir les pays d'afrique qui
connaissent un moment particulièrement
compliqué de leur histoire dans des pays
où les gens vivent au jour le jour ils
peuvent pas se permettre de rester
confinés un mois comme nous par exemple
un mois où faire leurs courses d'une
semaine de 1 mois et reste à la maison
fin d'action obligé de sortir pour aller
travailler pour en faire des courses ou
pour se réapprovisionner en feu et de
préciser vite c'est aussi de donner de
l'argent la main pour qu'il puisse
justement à voir ses provisions là est
resté confiné tranquillement en fait
pour acquérir encore plus vite et
essayer de combattre cette pandémie au
maximum au programme une ribambelle de
stars parmi lesquelles kalach kenji vita
antoine griezmann paul pogba inné sreg
ou encore cyril hanouna cyril qui a
décidé de rejoindre le live pour
soutenir son ami appeler aux dons mais
aussi contribuer à l'effort je voulais
t'appeler ce soir que tu es toujours là
pour toi comme tu es toujours là pour
moi et 33000 là à 22 heures grand direct
j'aimerais qu'on passe directe à 58 un
don qui a fait exploser de joie dazhou
[Musique]
au total en quatre heures de live
l'artiste a réussi à récolter 200 mille
euros de dons bravo à lui
bravo à mon badge ou d'amour qui a fait
un truc exceptionnel pour l'afrique est
pour et pour bien sûr et pour les
hôpitaux de france est juste voilà j'ai
fait qu'après la casquette j'ai un
brunch de ouf c'est vraiment jeu patrick
brochier